là plusieurs jours que la rumeur
persistante selon laquelle les messes de
protection que nous portons chaque jour
serait totalement inutile pour nous
protéger circulent sur internet
on ne compte plus les articles sur les
réseaux sociaux sur les dangers supposés
du masque pour notre santé une rumeur
qui a la vie dure car elle serait appuyé
par une étude de la très sérieuse
université de stanford aux etats-unis
une étude qui selon la publication va
encore plus loin puisqu'elle indique que
ces mêmes masque serait même dangereux
pour notre santé
non seulement le masque ne bloquerait
pas la transmission de la corrida pire
il causerait des dégâts physiques et
psychiques fait de l'intoxication
mentale
une publication rédigé par jean
dominique michel qui se décrit lui-même
comme un anthropologue de la santé sauf
que voilà si son cv semble en apparence
solide c'est sorti dans la presse autour
de lakovic 19 sont vivement contestée
par de nombreux spécialistes qu'ils
mettent en revanche nullement un expert
ni de la santé les deux leur apologie
une porte-parole de standford a quant à
elle indiqué que cette étude n'a pas été
publiée par leur université mais par un
magazine en ligne spécialisé dans les
théories radical sur la science alors le
masque et il en fait dangereux pour la
santé
ce soit dû me mohamed et face à antonio
et fabrice di vizio les bienvenus ici le
masque et il en fait dangereux pour la
santé
c'est vrai que cette histoire elle nous
fait un petit peu flipper on entend
beaucoup de gens dire ça on a entendu
hier aussi
martin blachier qui a dit que masque on
a ce qu'on extérieur était inutile
il évoque des études qui expliquait
comment se transmettait le comider que
il en a tiré une conclusion le macsquant
l'extérieur ne sert à rien enfin le
masque était dangereux est ce que pour
vous vous y croyez à ses études ou pas à
gilles verdez non l'étude de stands
sorbon l'université elle-même dément et
dit que c'est une manipulation donc
c'était une n'est pas crédible
il ya un anglais qui s'appelle tom
l'automne qui a couru 35 km avec un
masque pour montrer la différence
aucune différence donc le match n'est
pas dangereux et le mas protège bien
évidemment mais bon oui mais non mais
c'était à long terme
il a étudié et il ya aucune
problématique sur la dangerosité du mas
franchement aucune étudiantes ont aidé à
film parce que moi j'ai pas de preuve
irréfutable que le masque est dangereux
en revanche que j'aime pas c'est que
depuis le début on nous impose des idées
et on sait très bien que personne ne
connaît vraiment toute la vérité déjà le
masque sans être un expert je pense que
on a du mal à respirer mais j'ai du mal
à respirer quand je quand je porte un
masque on sait qu'il ya des problèmes de
poids aussi puis moi j'aime pas la
symbolique du masque j'aime pas l'idée
d'annemasse mouse et incite à
valenciennes c'est vrai nom mais bien
avant il fallait se découvrir quand on
rentrait dans un lieu public pendant
tout le monde est masqué c'est
l'anonymat ya plus d'émotions on est
tous caché donc la saison passée
l'ancien me dérange c'est d'ailleurs ici
moi je pense qu'on n'est pas fait pour
respirer ce qu on expire en fait on
expire quand même beaucoup de co2 et du
coup en même temps on en respire une
grande partie donc je pense que à la fin
de la journée à cause que si on a des
maux de tête ou si on est un peu
somnolent c'est effectivement parce que
on a restauré beaucoup de gaz carbonique
et puis deuxième chose dans un mas
comporte toute la journée
c'est dans une zone chaude et humide et
je pense que les micro organismes qui se
développent les sportifs de haut niveau
sont raides avec un masque pour
augmenter leur cabas bien sur ma wii
pour augmenter le cod dans le sens d'une
grosse bêtise et pour le coup le mas ça
fait 20 ans 30 ans 50 ans en tant que
les tout le monde en porte pour faire de
la médecine
béchir pour quoi demain ce serait la
journée n'avait la journée d'accord mais
c'est ça c'est pas du visible alors
guillemot avait d'abord avant qu'on
écoute les autres nous vous dites quoi
c'est quoi cette histoire s'est quand
même navrant qu'on en soit encore là un
an après avoir émis réellement
incroyable et j'entends certains
arguments le masque c'est inconfortable
c'est vrai que c'est désagréable on ne
voit plus les expressions des visages ça
peut donner effectivement des boutons
mais on sait ça sauve des vies
lorsque j'entendais le film parlait de
dioxyde de carbone chat ou précisé que
du dioxyde de carbone dernier dans la
pièce lorsque nous exclurons tous et
bien nous prenons une petite partie de
dioxyde de carbone
de la même façon lorsque vous avez un
masque eh bien il ya du dioxyde de
carbone qu'il a fuie sur les côtés donc
vous n'avez aucun risque pour votre
santé au contraire on sait que le port
du masque protège on a de nombreuses
études dont une énorme qu'on appelle une
méta-analyse c'est à dire un ensemble
d'études on a pris quasiment 180 études
dans 16 pays différents et on
s'intéressait à l'efficacité du port du
masque et on se rend compte de deux
choses 1 qu'on a besoin de distance
physique c'est pour ça qu'on soul les
gens et qu'on leur dit mettez-vous à
distance et que le port du masque est
associée à une diminution du risque non
seulement de la maladie mais en plus ce
qu'on appelle la charge virale ça veut
dire que si je porte un masque et que je
vous contamine car le masque n'est
jamais
parfait dans les transports en commun on
peut imaginer qu'un masque chirurgical
ne soit pas suffisamment efficace et
bien si vous vous portez un masque
vous allez probablement absorber une
plus petite quantité de virus et faire
une forme moins importante de la maladie
donc je pense qu'à l'heure actuelle on
est plutôt sur un débat comment
accélérer la vaccination plutôt que est
ce que le port du masque est dangereux
pour la santé
je pense qu'on se trompe de problème
valérie benalouane oui moi je suis allé
voir parce que je n'y connais rien je ne
suis pas un professionnel de santé met
donc je suis allée voir une dépêche afp
qui faisait du fact checking et c'est à
dire qu'il reprenait point par point la
fameuse vraie-fausse étude de stanford
qui n'est pas une équipe de stanford et
en fait ils ont repris point par point
auprès de médecins différents médecins
et ils ont démonté tous les soi-disant
arguments de ce monsieur jean dominique
michel anthropologue de la santé ce qui
ne veut absolument rien dire ça n'existe
pas c'est pas un métier qui existent on
peut inventer un métier peu importe si
quelqu'un qui étudie les comportements
voiture de santé il pas médecin voilà
mais ça existe c'est une pas légitimité
ou paraisse le port du masque d'accord
mais si ça pourrait être intéressant
d'ailleurs sur le plan social et sur le
plan met pas son corps médical et donc
ils sont revenus sur l'ipo xia pas
d'hypoxie sont revenus sur l'hyper cap
n'ya pas d'hyper cap nixon augmentation
dangereuse du taux d'acidité dans le
sens où il n'y en a pas et c ils ont
démonté point par point
alors moi je ne suis pas un scientifique
mais eux ce sont des scientifiques et
j'ai tendance à les croire eux plutôt
que ce monsieur
ils ont fait toutes les études de cas
pas d'hypoxie il n'y a pas dit plus
glouton des amis des popotes amusé voilà
oui et le jury
moi je suis d'accord sur le principe que
le masque sauvent des vies ne serait ce
que pour les gens qui ont des problèmes
de mauvaise haleine en fait c'est très
belle rentrée
sortie du numéro 12 du numéro 14 nicolas
non mais je ne joue pas on tombe sur
leurs deux choses on est encore le
vaccin ne sert à rien le masque ne sert
à rien alors il aidera d'études qui
existe de longue scène qui ont été
publiés encore dernièrement qui disent
que les particules
elles vont jusqu'à uimm être est elle
reste dans l'air derrière et 105 dire
des choses pareilles c'est quasiment
criminels mars que les gens sont perdus
aujourd'hui il pense que le vaccin est
dangereux il pense qu'aujourd'hui on
peut ne plus vivre sans porter de masque
et après on va dire quoi il convient d'
c'est pas dangereux l'on peut
[Rires]
effectivement il ya plusieurs jeux la
première c'est l'humidité cher
qu'aujourd'hui le syndrome de la
baguette magique n'existe pas il n'ya
pas le masque d'un côté versus rien de
l'autre il n'ya pas le vaccin versus
rien il ya on le disait que si mauvais
tout à l'heure je pense qu'on est
d'accord sur ce point il ya un ensemble
de choses qui agréger les unes aux
autres vont faire que on va en sortir il
ya pas deux il n'y a pas de ya pas de
miracle en fait en tant que tel
s'agissant du port du masque à deux
problèmes les trois problèmes qui quel
masque dans quelles circonstances
c'est ça la question est où alors qui ça
pose un problème par exemple le masque
sur les enfants ou le masseret à dieu
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
le masque sur les enfants c'est une
question qui est compliqué parce que
tellement vous êtes certaines études je
pense à harvard qui vous explique que
notamment chez des enfants handicapés
ça pose des problèmes de communication
donc ça c'est ils s'interrogent et ils
se demandent sur les enfants c est ce
que c'est obligatoire sur les dents
c'est obligatoire aujourd'hui en france
c'est obligatoire je croise un énorme et
ce que vous pensez qu'il faut le garder
obligatoires l'allemagne l'allemagne
la levée l'italie l'a levée sur les
enfants donc ça veut dire on va pas
tarder à tavannes l'italie la levée
errant qui avait pas de données
suffisantes pour établir une efficacité
du masque sur les petits en tout cas
donc c'est maintenant mais juste pour
cette étude donc du match ce qui serait
dangereux de la corse et napa valley -
bell est valable qu'aux les salles et
une annonce faite à l'epa stanford n'est
qu'à partir du moment où alassane fort
dès que vous avez quelqu'un allait de
check-list et une seule personne en fait
c'est un truc ccc l'air qui veut ça sert
qu'on est arrivé sur les réseaux sociaux
il ya un type qui a balancé un truc sur
facebook si j'ai bien compris entre
humains et qui a été un peu repris
manière virale sans réelle vérifications
mais stan sorte s'est désolidarisé très
vite d'accord une étude dont c'est
l'année c'est à dire ce qui est vrai
avec le port du masque
il ya un autre phénomène conquis et deux
problèmes un c'est que quand vous
regardez les états qui je pense au
dakota du nord qui a imposé le port du
masque versus le dakota du sud
finalement les courbes épidémiques sont
les mêmes vous avez le texas aujourd'hui
ça interroge j'ai pas de références mais
ça interroge ça interroge sur le fait
que des populations qui est abandonnée
le port du masque finalement se
retrouvent dans des dynamiques épidémie
qui n'ont pas explosé c'est une question
il faut là où je parle d'humilité fait
attention
deuxième élément moi j'ai fait une
requête récemment où je me suis fait
jeter mais pour réclamer le respect
d'eux dans les transports en disant
attention on peut pas mettre le même
masque final ça les deux dans un magasin
je raconte n'importe quoi ou la ligne 13
du métro c'est pas le même masque en
fait mon bas et c'est un peu le problème
c'est que derrière ce mot masque on a
mis une réalité indistincte la housse et
des situations différentes
je réponds quand même un argument sur le
chirurgien j'aime pas cet argument parce
que précisément il met presque contre le
chirurgien qui mêle masse ouais c'est
presque un argument contre pour moi dire
que s'ils auraient une raison alors de
militer contre le port du masque et le
chirurgien parce que quelque part le
chirurgien il le met dans sa contexte
particulier dans un environnement
particulier je pense pas que ça soit
comparable en fait d'accord c'est pas ça
le vrai débat en fait c'est aujourd'hui
moi je suis à l'origine du port du
masque à l'intérieur d'une session là
enfin je suis pas moi c'est mes clients
qu'ils soient bien que l'on voit c'est
vous et et et dieu sait si on a reproché
mais je crois aujourd'hui si vous voulez
que on n'est pas tout à fait mais on est
tout à fait au même point aujourd'hui il
faut commencer à s'interroger parce qu'à
une question qui se pose combien de
temps
jusqu'à quand à hollande c'est ça la
vraie question on arrête quand quand il
ya plus d'épidémie bombe attendent un
peu mal aux reins et quand tout le monde
est vacciné ça tient pas non plus y
aller seul problème c'est quand on fait
ce genre de mesures il faut être capable
de se dire à quel moment je les arrête
et c'est ça qui m'inquiète aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on n'a pas de perspective
sortie on peut on peut continuer de
porter des masques en ont mais la
réponse qu'on voulait avoir on l'a vu
aussi c'est que donc cette étude si vous
la voyez circuler les loyers sociaux
pis c'est pipeau djombo